is it too much of a leap to see veteran
as vep it's not a joke fedman got
smarter after his stroke as Dems take
offense at fetterman's Common Sense
Democrat Senator John fedman former
darling of the left now says
progressives left him it's true as his
party becomes more radical fedman has
come under attack for refusing to
support their insane positions the guy
had to get literal brain damage in order
to realize that his party is a
mess and
it's and it's caused controversy that he
just doesn't understand I honestly don't
understand why it's controversial to say
we we need a secure border and I think
two things can be true at the same time
you can be very supportive immigration
but we also need to have a secure border
and I really I think about immigration
is we want to provide the American dream
for any migrant but it seems very
difficult when you have 300,000 people
showing up encountered at at a quarter
to do that and I think we need to to re
do a reset and we have to work together
uh and develop uh a new comprehensive
solution to
that it's beautiful
actually the Democrats created a monster
and now he's turning on them as he
recovered his mind they left him behind
and who would have thought having a
stroke was the best thing that ever
happened to him could it be fedman
stroke was a stroke of
Genius whatever they did in his therapy
spread it around there's plenty in
Washington who could benefit from it I
also want to mention Congress Deborah
Ross where's
Deborah she I just had my picture taken
with her that's probably why she
left no all kid toab anyway you oh she
couldn't be here actually that's not
true I got mixed up
wow so why was just hanging out with
somebody who wasn't really there yeah
Emily I have to be honest I still feel
pretty bad for making fun of Federman I
feel like I need to make public and
private amends or something because it
turns out that he's like he he actually
was probably doing you know dealing with
a lot of stuff and now he's like
sensible am wait a minute what's
happening to me I
know what a jerk
let's
party um I I just okay first of all I'll
say this um I am always grateful for
anyone holding an elected position and
for his point a senate position that has
common sense so thank you that aside I
feel like we just watch someone go
through puberty in real time on our dime
I don't want to watch someone who sees
the light and comes to Jesus who in 2020
tweeted Jeb Bush like I'm the real
Progressive and I'm the most Progressive
and in his race said vote for me I'm the
most like he was he's been sort of a a
hack for many years and claiming that
he's the most Progressive and now that
we are realizing or we're watching him
realize that yes you have to have a bit
of Common Sense and they have left me
that that's what that identity crisis is
what's happening to a lot of Democrats
but sort of watching it happen and and
feeling like now we're supposed to
applaud I'm just grateful that someone
who has a d before his name might
actually be voting for common sense but
I don't feel like witnessing the
aggression like just get something done
then all right what do you what do you
think V Should we give him the benefit
of the doubt or should we crush him like
a bug the way Emily feels well I say my
my uh my background before was in
biotech and I will say that every
neurologist needs to study this man's
brain because what happened is nothing
short of a miracle and I will also say
if this means more Democrats need to
wear hoodies get rid of the suits and
bring them out I mean I'm fine with that
whatever gets the job done I'm in this
for the country
and so you know if somebody is saying
the right thing and heading in the right
direction and it's Earnest and and I was
watching him I wonder my first instinct
is this some kind of shtick I didn't get
the sense that it is and so anybody who
has an Earnest heartfelt change
sometimes I think a lot of politicians
create a box for themselves because they
weren't thinking when they were reading
what their super packs handed them as
their script but then they show up and
occasionally they actually say wait a
minute I was just reading that script
and I actually have independent thoughts
I think we got to applaud that or else
we create a disincentive for more people
to do it and the other thing is the
border now is officially a nonpartisan
issue as it should have been in the
first place that's a good thing and we
should celebrate it and I think that if
we own closing the Border as a leading
issue going into this campaign from
places like New York City to where we
are across this country I think this
could be a landslide win and if John
fedman proves it keep that hoodie coming
brother you know I'm happy to have you
you
know cat the opening thing said uh
Federman is vep wouldn't it be hilarious
if Trump chose him across the aisle said
I want want I want this fella over here
big guy
John I I don't think that'll happen um I
I I agree with you I think independent
thought should be encouraged I think
that just because someone has thoughts
outside of their party doesn't mean that
they're now in the other one yeah I
think it means they're thinking
independently but I'm just a little
upset about the video we just watched
like was was the president
hallucinating and we're supposed to just
be like okay with that he was he was why
isn't anyone going to tell what happened
I I don't know I don't know that was if
I started hallucinating on TV there
people would ask questions yeah exactly
that's like an outtake from the six
cents he was H he's like oh no I took a
picture with her he goes wait a minute I
can't be she's not here I just hute did
you so why did you think that you did
yeah why did you think that you did if
she's not here I ask it's very simple
why did you think you took a picture
with her when she was not there did you
see her at some point and think she was
there were you thinking of another time
no I'm just like I know this stuff
happens all the time it happens all the
time so a lot of people are like oh
that's just Joe being Joe again like
that's not enough for me that's not
enough for me why did you think you took
a picture with somebody that was not
there I know and that I think I that I
bet that's the first time people have
seen that right it was like it was
buried yeah it was buried much like well
oh that there was a joke I was going to
make but you know what I'm just going to
leave the jokes to Adam
like a part of me thinks fedman is just
jealous cuz the migrants are dressed
better than him um I mean Goodwill sends
him clo uh but he's right about the
Border I mean it's more open than Will
Smith marriage right now and
um so I know but I don't know if we're
going to solve it like I think that we
need to capitalize it like I think we
should put obstacle course On the Border
MH film it call it Mexican Ninja Warrior
oh
nice and
I like it I like it all right up next
can Taylor Take a Hint about her carbon
footprint hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else